i'm gonna start today with the the
prototypical story really that is an
objectively important story to
understand what's going on in the
economy
and that almost no one cares about and
almost no one will watch or engage with
but it doesn't matter it's actually an
important story so we're going to start
with it and the story is that the
federal reserve has raised interest
rates by what's called sometimes 50
basis points or half a percent when they
say 50 what they mean is
0.50 percent this is the biggest
increase in 22 years since the year 2000
and so much of what's going on today
that is flippantly mentioned in in so
many of these 2022 debates that you can
tell the candidates don't really
understand
comes down to understanding what is the
impact of raising raising or lowering
the federal funds rate and so that's
what we're going to talk about and
before i get into the details
yesterday we watched and we live
streamed the 2022
pennsylvania republican senate primary
debate this is the one with mehmet oz
and dave mccormick and carla sands and
kathy barnett etc
bartos i think is the fifth guy now i'm
actually remembering their names and
they were asked all of them asked about
inflation and balancing the budgets and
the economy and so many different things
and all five of them expressed no
knowledge whatsoever of how these basic
tools that are available to different uh
government entities work with the
exception of at one point mehmet oz
mentioned
raising the rate to lower inflation and
that was true but then he moved on and
went beyond it so let's jump into the
details and then we'll explain what's
going on
yahoo finance report
fed raises interest rates
0.5 percent largest move since the year
2000. good
this is the short-term interest rate
this is an effort to tamp down on the
inflationary pressures weighing on
americans the central bank suggested it
will further raise borrowing costs
throughout this year as it attempts to
undo its pandemic era easy money
policies
uh the policy setting federal open
market committee also detailed plans on
unwinding its nearly nine trillion
dollar balance sheet
the raising of rates a half a percent is
the most aggressive increase in a single
meeting since may of 2000 over the last
two decades the fed has opted to raise
interest rates in increments of a
quarter of a percent only
so
let's talk about this what how how does
the the rate goes up
and inflation goes down how does that
work well
when you raise the federal funds rate
you make it more expensive for banks to
borrow money
when it's more expensive for banks to
borrow money
they in turn make it more expensive for
people like you and me and businesses to
borrow money when it's more expensive
for us to borrow money we do less
borrowing and when you see the ways in
which this is impactful it will start to
make intuitive sense so if it becomes
more expensive to get a mortgage that's
one form of borrowing
that makes a three hundred thousand
dollar house more expensive what i mean
by that is the house might be three
hundred thousand dollars either way but
if my mortgage on it is five and a
quarter percent instead of five percent
now that same three hundred thousand
dollar house is more expensive for me so
instead of spending three hundred
thousand on a house i might only spend
290. so that pushes down people's
budgets and it can push down housing
prices or at least slow down the
increase that's one component
uh vehicles car loans if car loans are
more expensive you might be less likely
to get a car loan or if you do you'll
get a cheaper car that pushes down on
price increases it discourages spending
and it can lower inflation now many
people will say but david it can also
slow down the economy well how how does
that work same principle one of the ways
that an economy grows is by people
investing in their own businesses
oftentimes people times people borrow to
invest in their business imagine that i
want to start
a shoe business and i need a factory and
i need to borrow in order to build that
factory well if it's more expensive to
borrow i'm less likely to do it or i'm
less likely to borrow as much meaning
that instead of maybe having four
hundred thousand dollars to build my
factory which would go to contractors
and lawyers and insurance and local
businesses now i only have three hundred
thousand dollars so i'm slowing down
economic growth in that way it always is
the case
that every one of these decisions is a
double-edged sword it is always the case
and so very often you see
hyper partisan discussions where we
shouldn't raise rates because that will
slow down the economy right but it could
also lower inflation which many of you
claim to want to do well we shouldn't
lower rates because it makes it too easy
to borrow
and therefore it will cause inflation
well yes that that's the that's the way
it works that's the double-edged sword
and the whole strategy the whole trick
of it is to keep these things uh in in
balance one other way in which raising
the funds rate discourages spending and
it can both lower inflation but slow
down the economy
if
if if anybody has a savings account i
was going to call it a high yield
savings account but there's very little
high yield about it many so-called
high-yield savings accounts over the
last couple of years at the most pay
about half a percent there's a number of
high-yield savings account where you can
earn 0.5 percent not a great incentive
to just store your money because it's
lower than inflation
if the federal funds rate goes up half a
point
and thus high yield savings accounts pay
you more interest you might lean a
little more towards now i'm more okay
just saving the money and earning the
interest because the interest rate is a
little bit higher and instead of putting
that money into the economy you just
save it so that that's another aspect to
this every single one of these things
can have multiple effects and um that is
the importance of raising the federal
funds rate so we'll see what the impact
is
and uh we will see what forthcoming
additional increases there are and we've
been we've been warned to expect more i
hope that that's clear or at least
relatively simple
if it's not let me know and also let me
know if these types of segments are
useful
there is another
audio recording of house minority leader
kevin mccarthy who's a republican making
it very clear
that he wants trump out this is truly
incredible stuff and it actually it's
not improving my opinion of mccarthy
it's actually worsening it and i'll
explain why new audio reports cnn
mccarthy said 25th amendment takes too
long
in other words the 25th amendment would
take too long to remove trump he wanted
as a republican who publicly supported
trump privately mccarthy wanted trump
removed wanted to reach out to biden
after the january 6th attack this is
incredible
house republican leader kevin mccarthy
discussed the 25th amendment this is a
mechanism to remove a sitting president
on a call with republican leadership
days after the january 6 2021 attack on
the capital and said the process takes
too long according to audio obtained by
the new york times and shared with cnn
he also said he wanted to reach out to
then president-elect biden to hope for a
smooth transition and said he thought an
impeachment would further divide the
nation let's listen to that audio
revealed yesterday to cnn by the new
york times reporters this is incredible
stuff
yeah but what the president did is
atrocious and totally wrong
um
you're 12 days away
i mean at one point i make this fight
if you have an impeachment and you're
stuck sitting in the senate and he needs
cabinet members you've got secretary
you put everything else away this
country is very very divided i do think
the impeachment divides the nation
further and continues the fight is
greater
um that's why
i want to reach out to biden i wanted
the president to leave goodbye but
that's not going to happen
i want to see about i was meeting with
bibi and sitting down
make a
to show that
and continue to keep those statements
going
um so hopefully i know he's going to
talk to pelosi that he's going to i
hopefully he calls me today
and see if we can start that process
this is incredible stuff
truly
okay that's the end of the clip
uh this makes these people look way
worse so every time we we learn
something like this
there's kind of two perspectives right
there's well one perspective is
these people aren't as crazy as we
thought
in the sense that
they realized how dangerous trump was
and they actually did want him gone
that's one perspective they're not as
bad
the other perspective is these people
are even worse because it's not that
they genuinely believed
trump won
and the riots were good and all this
different stuff they knew the opposite
was true but they continued publicly
saying
uh the things that they had to say in
order to stay in trump's good graces or
whatever the case may be
i believe that the latter is accurate
these people are worse because kevin
mccarthy knew better he knew better he
was saying it he was on the phone with
liz cheney he was on the phone with
whoever and he continued to pander
and to risk american democracy because
of whatever selfish or self-centered
reasons made him do it publicly
um he says oh it was atrocious and it
was totally wrong what trump did we got
to look at the 25th amendment um and yet
publicly he just continued to do his
thing and say no everything's good
republicans are good everything's good
so is it a desire for power and money
and continuing to have access to the
president that influenced it is there
some connection and we're speculating
here between whatever made
ted cruz and lindsey graham 180 on trump
remember the the those were not people
who ever supported trump early
and then all of a sudden they love trump
they think he's great is there some
connection between that and whatever
kept mccarthy publicly supporting trump
could it be as simple as polling they
saw listen most of the base supports
this guy so we've got to support this
guy
all of this confirms
mccarthy
is sane enough to know about the
toxicity and the atrocity of trump and
yet he still actively chose to allow it
and that makes him i believe worse than
if he was a true believer and this kind
of gets back to the conversation we've
been having for a week or two now about
what's worse the true believers or the
false believers the 25th amendment was
exactly for situations like these where
the president has become so compromised
he can't think straight he can't
discharge his duty as president of the
united states he's lost his mind and
some of the people closest to him
i guess they knew it had been enough but
they chose not to act and they continue
republicans do to tell democrats now
that they've got to clean up the mess
that it's actually republicans and
trumpists who created now one other
question
we've been playing these recordings of
kevin mccarthy for weeks now
has fox even talked about them
do fox news viewers even know that these
recordings exist i genuinely don't know
the answer i mean it's not like i sit
around and watch fox do they have any
idea
of what we've learned from these
recordings over the last few weeks i
don't know the answer to that but if the
answer is no
this goes to our story about two
americas that exist and it's uh very
very disturbing stuff let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at d
pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
we are an audience supported program and
on that note i'd love for you to support
the work that we do the daily podcast
youtube clips tv show radio show live
streams premium newsletter all of the
different things
the easiest way is to sign up at
joinpackman.com it's quick it's easy
there's no big company taking 10 20 30
slices of every dollar we keep
everything but a 2.9
payment processing fee and you can get a
discount using the coupon code obama
major discount in fact i won't even tell
you how big of a discount it is it's a
lit it makes me blush how big of a
discount it is you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
president joe biden is under fire
because he said that the so-called maga
crowd
is the quote most extreme political
group in us history and he is exactly
right and i know many of you will say
but sir what about the kkk or what about
the i am going to get to that in a
moment um and uh let's take a look first
at what joe biden said axios reporting
president biden on wednesday said the
maga crowd is really the most extreme
political organization that's existed in
american history while speculating on
how conservative state legislatures
could respond to a potential supreme
court ruling that would drastically
curtail abortion access this was when tr
biden was taking questions from
reporters about the leaked draft opinion
of the roe v wade decision let's take a
look at this video and what joe biden
said and then we will discuss what
happens if you have a state changes the
law saying that that that children who
are lgbtq campaign classrooms with other
children right
is that is that legit under the way that
the decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history
okay so he clarifies and says in recent
american history now i actually think
the addition of recent is important and
i'll get back to what i think of when he
says recent but let's talk about it
because joe biden is correct i've been
saying this for a long time and i'm glad
that he is saying it so let's take the
obvious counterpoint well what about a
group like the kkk the ku klux klan for
example the kkk
was not an actual prominent political
group
in recent american history the the kkk
if you've looked at kkk history there's
sort of like um a different uh they call
them like the first clan the second clan
the third clan the estimated peak of the
second clan was in the mid 1920s
and it's estimated that at that point
the kkk had 3 to six million members
only some of whom actually voted so as a
political
first of all you could say it's not even
really a political movement but let's
let's give let's say it is even as a
political movement
there were 74 million people who voted
for president trump
in 2020 and a ton of them are part of
what we would call the maga movement not
all i mean there are some republicans
there who just didn't like hillary and
they didn't like biden but
we're talking about a group that at
least at the top line is 74 million
people the peak of the second clan was
three to six million in the 1920s more
recently the anti-defamation league
estimates that there's about 30 active
kkk groups with like three to six
thousand members so
statistically i mean joe biden is
correct uh this this is
the most extreme political group and the
only confusion to me is why did biden
think or say that he could quote work
with them as he did during the campaign
maybe he just felt he had to say it
and i would understand that
it may not be well received if you're
biden and you know you can't work with
these lunatics if during your campaign
you go i don't even intend to listen to
these people
it probably doesn't play well so i i
understand that um now let's talk about
the addition of in in recent history
if we think back to the civil war
and many of you will immediately know
where i'm going with this
the confederacy
do you have to go back to the
confederacy to find
a political movement as extreme as mega
i think maybe you do
and so that's why the kind of addition
of recent history by joe biden maybe
clarifies or even puts puts a better
kind of point on it the question i am
concerned with and i know many of you
are concerned with because you email me
about it all the time is okay how do we
deprogram them how do we de-radicalize
millions of people and we've talked
about techniques before we've talked
about
empathy
listening building relationships this
takes a really long time it's got to be
done basically one on one or maybe one
on two or something like that but in
order to really de-radicalize magga
and by de-radicalizing i mean they're
only held together by their radicalism
so when we say de-radicalize we're
probably talking about an evaporation of
the movement you have to deal with
steve bannon roger stone trump himself
michael flynn fox news infowars newsmax
oan dan bongino ben shapiro breitbart
all these different things
as well as the social media algorithms
that amplify the stuff that they post
if you don't deal with that you're not
going to fix it the problem is
i don't think we can just start
de-platforming i just i just don't think
so not only
does it go against some of our
principles importantly
but
it would cause a backlash it would
potentially cause a significant increase
of physical violence from the devoted
maggas so you know don't get me wrong
everybody who's committed a crime
january 6 trump riots uh uh terroristic
threats all these different things
charge them throw the book at them etc
but just like a nasty platforming
movement isn't in line with leftist
values and it also wouldn't be effective
so i don't think that's that's the
answer and then that leaves us with the
question of well what is the answer and
we don't know we don't always have the
answers and the reason i've been
interviewing cult experts
conspiracy experts etc is to try to get
ideas about what might actually work
always open to hearing ideas from you as
well i want to play a few clips for you
today
of a monstrous donald trump being
interviewed by the christian
broadcasting network and declaring
himself a christian savior
this is really a wild god complex that
donald trump has it's like a jesus
complex i guess you would say uh let's
start with this first clip where trump
claims no one ever
has done more for christianity and for
all religions than trump himself you
know nobody has done more for
christianity nobody has done more for
religion of all type than me
and they're really
doing things now too and i've always
said it they are against organized
religion
they're against
christianity and of course no we're not
what we are against is civil law based
on christian doctrine
we're against enmeshing church and state
we're against discrimination
against non-christians or simply
non-believers remember
non-religion is protected and the
absence of religion is equally protected
but trump with a real god complex now i
do want to say
i don't think trump is the person who's
done the most for
christianity and all religions as he
claims but
if indeed
the leaked supreme court decision holds
and i believe it will we know it's an
accurate draft but it's a draft from
february if it holds in a few weeks when
it's released and roe v wade is
overturned
trump will be responsible for one of the
major accomplishments i would call it a
major coup but that term now we you've
got to be careful with that term we want
to be clear about what we mean
it would be one of the major
accomplishments of the retrograde
religious conservative movement
overturning roe v wade after four four
decades
uh really pieces of five decades
actually actually no it's just five
decades i don't even have to hedge uh
would be an absolute major
accomplishment and uh trump is
responsible for that he's the guy who
appointed the justices that made it
possible let's go to the next clip here
is donald trump
uh sort of uh now
on the on the heels of uh what was it jp
jd mandel no jd vance winning his
primary on tuesday night and j.r
majewski winning his primary on tuesday
night trump feels emboldened about the
power of his endorsement and he's
telling everybody else
i don't endorse you it's very bad i
remember joe biden saying months ago at
this press conference he had that he
goes you couldn't believe all these
republicans still afraid of trump was
like oh they're all afraid of trump
should republicans be afraid of you the
ones that are are not in line with you
and your
views well if they want to win
politically probably because if i
endorse them they win and if i don't
endorse them they don't win i mean
that's almost 100 of the case now it's
really more like 57 of the case and i
think it's really important to remember
that although trump did get two
victories so far this primary uh season
and he may get more there's no question
trump may get more trump's record on
endorsements is pretty pretty shoddy
it's kind of like swiss cheese first of
all
he endorsed a lot of uh presumptive
front runners and incumbents and there's
a major incumbency bias in american
politics and even given all that his
record is not that great like it's
hovering right around and slightly below
60 percent so it's not actually true
that uh everybody trump touches turns to
gold but
it may end up being true in 2022 remains
to be seen one last clip here here's
trump talking about disney of course
disney now under fire for opposing
florida's don't say gay bill and people
are protesting at disney and they want
to cancel mickey and minnie and all
these different things anyway trump says
walt disney wouldn't be happy with
what's going on i think what's happened
with disney and what disney's doing walt
disney is looking down what's he
thinking he's not happy okay walt disney
said whatever happened to my beautiful
magic kingdom
uh he's not happy
no it's uh
it's a terrible thing so anyway
there's trump uh speculating on how walt
disney would feel about the magic
kingdom today uh based on disney's
opposition to the don't say gay bill the
the don't say gay bill is of course
disgusting
and uh i hate theme parks and have no
interest in ever going to disney again
but uh i like disney's taking a position
on this and by the way disney wouldn't
take a position on this i don't think
if they didn't calculate that it's
probably an okay pr move to take the
position that they did opposing the
don't say gay bill a very strange
interview with donald trump but an
emboldened donald trump on the heels of
some primary endorsement successes we'll
have these video clips for you if you're
just listening to the podcast today or
maybe listening on the radio we'll have
these video clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with matthew tai known
online as lao y 86 or sea milk who's an
american blogger well known for living
in china
matthew so great having you on i really
appreciate it
ah thank you so much it's an honor so i
mean i guess first just to kind of
orient our our audience how did you end
up living in china for the the period
that you did
yeah i'll give you the cliff notes
version but basically i was you know
bored out of college i didn't really
want to settle down and get a job
immediately um i had just backpacked
through europe i was like why not go
travel somewhere else
uh china wasn't even on my list i was
like why not do some sort of gap year
maybe teach you know teach english
abroad for a year and then come back
home and then get a job so i initially
thought you know taiwan sounds pretty
cool uh interested in maybe learning
mandarin chinese might be useful in the
future
so i put up my resume on some taiwanese
job sites and it just wasn't hiring
season at the time
uh but i guess some mainland chinese
companies also poach like potential
employees on those sites as well because
i got a phone call from this like uh
tiny tiny little school in guangdong in
huizhou actually the picture behind me
is the city behind me um called me up
and said hey do you want to do a year
here instead and i you know i didn't
really consider i was like you know
china is a pretty seems like a pretty
crazy place but at the same time why not
go on another adventure and try it out
and
you know sold all my stuff i was just a
young you know 22 year old kid and uh
hopped on a plane and went over there
and
i have a number of viewers who have
called me sometimes when we'll open up
our phone lines and they say that they
are in china teaching english um
what other things do americans sometimes
do in china when they're there
sure yeah like so i didn't continue
teaching english the entire time it's
kind of just your it's the way you get
when you get off the plane it's what you
do right but a lot of people you know
they'll oversee factories they'll um
do consultation for like uh what's it
called like quality control
they'll do
um help with immigration visas and stuff
for people that want to move abroad
um there's people that will start their
own bars you know it's like a it's not
an open market but it's a huge market so
a lot of people especially during
china's golden period which i call like
kind of like when i was there
2008 up until i mean i left in around
2018 but up until like 2014 was like a
golden period for people to go there
and try out a new market go try a new
product try to get chinese people
interested in something that they can
find a home that is not already popular
in china
so
there's how to even broach this next
part i mean there's no shortage of
reporting about
an authoritarian status quo in china to
different degrees and affecting
different people
we have um
the uyghur population specifically and
we've done interviews about that then
there's people like you who are
americans who may be there on a
temporary basis and your circumstances
presumably would be different than
someone who is from china and living in
china just to get us into this can you
give us a general overview of what's
accurate about the reporting that we
hear about the chinese government and
what maybe is is less accurate generally
speaking
sure so when i was initially there i
mean i didn't set out to cover any news
or influence anything about china um
other than the fact that i wanted to put
out videos to show people that it's not
the boogeyman like people are like what
are you doing over there why did you
move to such a crazy you know communist
authoritarian country and i just wanted
to put videos out there to be like
listen it's not it's not as bad as what
you think or maybe the things that
you're thinking of are not actually true
at least in my life from my perspective
or my chinese friends right so
that's what i initially did and um
i actually moved into as my channel got
bigger and stuff and i you know my
business partner people might know him
out there winston he's uh the first
china vlogger the first guy to actually
get on a vpn and put out videos from
china i happen to be the second we met
each other um we started doing tv shows
we started doing travel documentaries
and again our goal
was we set up a a small motorcycle
business where we built our own custom
motorcycles and we rode through the
country and we rode we didn't go through
the places like that you know people
normally see shanghai beijing we went
through the rural countryside we went
through the small towns the third tier
cities all these places that don't get
reporting
so we wanted to show
a human face of china and we didn't set
out to do that from the lens of like
oh this is so unfair the way it's
portrayed we just wanted to show reality
right
so from that perspective we developed
our own insight onto what was actually
happening in the country
and as we traveled more and the more
people and relationships we developed
the more we realize that
unfortunately a lot of stuff that people
talk about in regards to china are more
of a macro scale
but
china has a lot of issues and a lot of
them i'm going to say the majority of
them do stem from the chinese government
and when we would go to
some of these villages and find out that
maybe an official for example a local
official went unpunished after raping a
14 year old girl and then having her
murdered
we would be shocked to hear this and
it's weird because the people in this
village they normally probably wouldn't
talk about that to anyone else but
because we were foreigners that showed
up there was some sort of like trust or
understanding that they that we would
understand
we would kind of get their perspective
and we wouldn't stick around long enough
to face any repercussion and the more
people like that we met the more
beholding we felt to tell the story of
actually what's happening when we were
in
some of these far-flung areas we would
find out that the people's liberation
army of china would go and harass
families and harass tribes like
mongolian tribes and things like this
for money
to just keep them down their languages
were being banned out of schools um the
people would tell us stories about how
they felt trapped because they're an
ethnic minority and china doesn't allow
them mobility or doesn't allow them to
do really anything especially upwards of
mobility owning their own business
making money
and we found out that there's actually a
lot more than what you know western
media is portraying i think the western
media portrays a lot of you know
financial based things or you know we'll
focus on one specific issue which is
great i mean like i i absolutely um
focus on the uyghur issue it's a huge
thing i personally know uyghur people
that have gone through this i'm in
personal contact with people that have
lost their families to the genocide in
western china but also like the stories
of the inner mongolian people the
stories of the ethnic minorities in the
south um i became very dedicated to kind
of compiling these stories in my head
while i was there knowing i couldn't
report from china at the time and then
saving them for when i ultimately had to
leave china so let's dig into a couple
things you said you said you in some of
the you know third tier cities you
wouldn't stick around long enough that
there would be repercussions and then
you just said some of the stories you
knew you couldn't report on while you
were there
why why not why did you have to leave
the cities what would the repercussions
be what would happen if you tried to
report on them
so what happened was when we we would
have the the nicest of intentions let's
say we show up at a you know a third
fourth fifth tier city somewhere down in
guejo province let's just pick a random
province in the south
and what would happen is we would get
you know of course you show up you're a
foreigner from the middle of nowhere
like you're in the middle of nowhere
people crowd around you they want to
talk to you they want to take pictures
with all that kind of stuff that's
normal but
when you sit down with people and you
start sharing a meal when you start
talking about things and they you know
you're not inciting these conversations
they're they're bringing these things up
and they start talking about what life
is like there how they haven't received
any of the poverty you know alleviation
type funds how their their town
is going to be flooded by a dam that the
government's putting in even though that
nobody wants it there those
conversations perk the wrong ears so
like people will be in the background
people will be around there that have to
report to local communist party
officials and what will happen is
they'll find out you know through the
grapevine quite quickly that there's
foreigners there and that they're not
supposed to be there because there are
entire areas in china where foreigners
are not even supposed to be and you
don't hear about this this is again you
wouldn't see this on reporting you
wouldn't read about this anywhere but
there are whole areas that are basically
blacklisted off because the chinese
government doesn't want another xinjiang
story to break they don't want another
tibet story to break they don't want
people talking about issues that are
caused by the government leaking out to
potential journalists even though we
weren't
um so
you would have a situation where you'd
be in an area and then you'd kind of get
this inkling this feeling that
number one the hotels won't even let you
stay stay there they're like no we can't
register a foreigner you know whether
they got tipped off by someone or not
it's a different story but they just
won't even register you so you can stay
there so you're forced to leave anyway
but when you get the feeling that people
are starting to like make phone calls
and then you start to see police
officers and things like this you know
it's time to leave because the times
that we did stick around we've been told
by police officers that you actually
have to get on your bike and just get
the hell out of there wow and what we
notice sometimes is when we would be in
these areas later on we would see
actual police officers sometimes in
notepads or their phones
at certain kind of designated points on
the road from the next from where we
just left to the next city so we'd be
monitored the entire time and you
realize that you know especially when
you travel around rural china
you realize that it's very much akin to
the security apparatus that maybe like a
place like north korea would have it's
just not as in your face and it has more
money right so you're minded the entire
time and ultimately we found out really
how bad it can get when we were up in
inner mongolia and you know our hotel
room was just full of swat team people
with body cameras and automatic weapons
that's when you realize that i'm here
trying to film some horses and talk to
some local people about their way of
life and then there's a swat team and
detectives in my hotel room
interrogating me about my every movement
in the entire country
um now when something like that happened
after they're done interrogating you do
they leave and then you just kind of
finish what you were doing
no that's that's the worst part is that
there's a a system of i don't know i
think they want to instill some sort of
paranoia because what they'll do
is uh i'll use the example in the hotel
room with a swat team what they'll do is
be like
okay we didn't really get what we wanted
you know they they list off where we
work what our contracts were where we
shop 2 000 miles away by the way they
know everything about you and they want
to get in your head because later on
they'll continue to harass you so you
think everything's fine you'll leave
super early the next morning to go on to
your next destination and then you get
stopped by the army like that that later
that day uh early in the morning we got
stopped by the pla the people's
liberation army who made us take apart
all of our equipment check everything
take photos told us not to smile in the
photo stand in front of everything and
they would leave
and then immediately they would come
back and do the exact same thing over
and over again until you just get out of
their jurisdiction right at the same
time after your trip is over the police
still come to your house they come to
visit where you are they come to
interrogate you why why do you own a
drone why are you doing this right and
it's this constant kind of harassment
and it's
it's kind of the
the moment you realize that hey i'm not
welcome here with a camera they don't
want people they don't want foreigners
walking around with cameras talking to
people and so that kind of false
security you've built up over 10 years
you know you watch that shift with the
the current regime by the way this this
really came to fruition maybe around
2015 and started getting really bad
um but you watch this happen and it
breaks your heart and it also makes you
feel like what if if the chinese
government's trying to hide this stuff
so badly there is so there's so much
under the surface that people don't
actually know about and that's what i
feel
beholden you know i feel beholden to the
people to talk about today because i i
get thousands thousands of chinese
people reaching out telling me please
keep your voice up please keep talking
about this kind of stuff because we
can't talk about that stuff right right
the um the social credit system i i've
read quite a bit about it specifically
in the context of the uyghurs and we
interviewed jeffrey kane about his book
and and he you know writes specifically
about how how it's sometimes used uh to
restrict the movement of the weaker
people and in other ways can you talk a
little more generally just about how for
the average person living in china and
maybe there is no such thing maybe it's
very different urban versus rural or
whatever the case may be sure how does
that system affect the average person
yeah so the social credit system is i've
done a huge uh
basically a documentary series on the
whole thing
what it is is it's more of a dynamic
thing that's being tested out so i think
a lot of people you know i wanted to go
out there and dispel this myth that it's
some sort of number that hangs over your
head like a black mirror or something
it's not it's not that at all in fact it
was it was rolled out in this place
called rongchang in shandong in northern
china
and it was the first place that they
they rolled it out and it's no secret in
fact i found the
government documents that are out there
in public and i translated them myself
and that's what i based my video on
and what it did was teach me how it
works you know from a you know a test
standpoint testing out on this city and
its people which it's mandatory there
but it's not necessarily something
that's used elsewhere right there are
other cities in fact i reached out to a
lot of people around china to ask them
if they even knew about it i would say a
good chunk of people hadn't even heard
about it but then there were there were
cities there were other cities and like
in chengdu and then i talked to people
in anhui i talked to people all over
china that did know about it in fact
their city had some sort of version of
it and what it is it's really trying to
reward good behavior
with a point-based system and then
punish bad behavior and unfortunately
when i went through those documents and
i spoke to people around china
it
looks like it's trying to reward good
societal behavior which is probably a
fine it's a fine thing it's like uh you
know yeah i don't have a criminal record
so my score goes higher right but
unfortunately a good proportion of those
crimes of those things that lower your
score
are things about
speaking out against the government
about posting uh messages of dissent on
on forums or on on chat groups um you
know
having
weird religious beliefs as they call it
you know cult-like religious beliefs it
turns out that a lot of it is aimed at
reducing personal freedom
so that people don't dissent against the
government
once you're sort of branded or
stigmatized or assigned you know a
lesser status whether it's specifically
point-based or not
how do you recover from that how can how
can you get back to sort of being on on
everyone's good side so to speak
well unfortunately if you're on like the
low
this is what i pointed out in my in my
video series is that when i spoke to
people there's no
even though there's a sliding scale of
points if the government deems you the
lowest score you just get the lowest
score there's no there's no rule of law
or rhyme or reason in this i think
people really rely on this western lens
of like everything works to a certain
standard everything works because of
rules and laws that's not really how it
works like if china wants to throw you
the lowest score and make you like
ostracize in society they'll just do
that right off the bat right especially
if it's something about the government
or destroy you in jail but if a person
is like labeled at the bottom i mean
your your kids probably aren't going to
get into schools right um you know
you're not going to be able to get
employment opportunities at least above
the lowest you know blue collar kind of
construct construction type jobs even if
you're well educated um
and to get out of that if you're at the
bottom you're not going anywhere but if
you to get out of that you have to do
good deeds right you have to uh
participate in in local government uh
activities you have to
i mean there are there are some clauses
in these documents that say if you rat
someone out basically that's doing bad
things then you get to move up it's
basically
a
really restrictive way of keeping people
in their spot they don't really want
people to go up or down necessarily
um
it's almost like there is no recourse
for people to
exit once they've already been deemed
that lower caste
last thing i want to ask about in a
couple minutes we have left you weren't
there during the coveted lockdowns but
it's been widely reported that you know
there are these videos of the
vehicles pumping out disinfectant on the
street which is of course of
questionable or no actual preventative
value for covert whatsoever the covet
zero strategy of a sort of close to
complete lockdown
um etc etc can you talk a little bit
about whether any of what
you read about in the context of covid
was surprising based on your experiences
when you did live live there
um no
honestly like when i see
when i saw the heavy-handed approach of
you know xi jinping's government
uh really not just when he took over but
like later on when he achieved full full
power within this within the chinese
government when he consolidated that
power through the anti-corruption drive
and things like this i wasn't surprised
to see what kind of methodology was
coming out with the the zero covert
policy because
there's a there's a thing within the
chinese government especially especially
true under the current leadership
is that they can't be wrong
so when the chinese government set out
to say hey look at the world failing
with the coveted response
look at we're going to be the ones that
kind of deal with it very harshly in the
beginning but we're going to show the
world as kind of as a brand how this
authoritarian style government actually
works right we can take away people's
personal freedoms and stuff but isn't
that better than dying isn't that better
than millions of people dying and
honestly it kind of worked in the
beginning i think a lot of people were
like you know china's pretty brutal but
at the same time you know look at how
they've dealt with this a lot of people
didn't die in comparison to the rest of
the world that's i guess if you believe
the numbers right i mean there's also a
question as to yeah but of course
yeah i'm always speaking uh like a
normal reader yes looking at the news
right right um let's pretend like you
believe the number so
then people are in a position to say you
know what this other style of governance
maybe they're not going to jump on and
be like yeah china's the future china's
the way but they'll look at it and say
you know what maybe this kind of
reporting that i see about china is not
really accurate right
and what happens is unfortunately when
you get new variants when you get
something that spreads so
crazy like omicron and then the rest of
the world has found out ways to deal
with it whether it be mrna vaccinations
on things that have been proven to work
china didn't adopt those things out of
face to save face to say that we have
our own homegrown method we have our own
vaccine which is not very effective by
the way again
we have our own lockdown strategies and
we've already put in the work so we
don't really have to suffer through this
anymore while you guys still have to and
the rest of the world's kind of saying
what do you mean like it's not number
one it's not as the the new variant's
not as bad number two a lot of our
population is vaccinated and number
three we have an actual dynamic approach
on how to deal with it that doesn't
necessarily restrict people's personal
freedoms and china says nope nope
blinders on we have zero kovid we have
zero code we have zero covered and that
can't be proven wrong because in the top
down leadership in china there is no
there is no saying that the government
is wrong about their strategy they have
to be right and see it through
we're seeing where xi jinping is
currently trying to get into his third
term he has to make sure
that his policies
not only worked but nobody has any sort
of dissent or disapproval with them
right so we're looking at a situation
now where zero covid is either going to
change and rebrand to the to save leader
leadership face or is going to continue
down this very draconian route
we've been speaking with matthew tai
known online as laowai 86 or sea milk uh
matthew's so great speaking to you and
really appreciate your insights
thank you so much david
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
well i have an opportunity today to do
two things that i think are valuable one
is debunk a false talking point that is
spreading like wildfire
and number two to remind everybody that
the entire tulsi gabbard thing was a
complete and total scam uh tulsi gabbard
who
so i guess somebody
thought was on the left at one point
when she ran for president and when she
was a democrat she continues to provide
reactionary takes on fox news
and last night she provided a
reactionary take that is a great
opportunity to explain reality uh to her
and to people in the audience and to
make sure that we're all equipped with
the truth about this question did the
supreme court leaker
commit a crime
because for all the talk about due
process that the right claims to support
they are increasingly demanding the
prosecution and imprisonment of the
supreme court leaker
absent any actual
crime that we can point to that they
committed so let's start with tulsi you
might be shocked that tulsi appeared to
express outrage
that the decision leaked
not that women's autonomy will now be
allowed to be restricted by states
she was outraged that we learned about
this three weeks early let's take a
listen to be heard i think it's also
critical to point out that
this leak sets a very very dangerous
precedent for our supreme court for
three important reasons number one is
first of all this person is a thief who
stole this information released it with
a very specific intent to try to incite
protesters and intimidate and pressure
our supreme court justices to make a
political decision rather than a
decision that is based on the
constitution
number two we have the fact that
you know the supreme court is not in
place to legislate from the bench uh
people's representatives and yet that's
exactly what they're doing with this
decision state level at the federal
level are charged to make laws not the
supreme court the supreme court needs to
make decisions uh based on the
constitution
and the department of justice lastly
needs to go and prosecute this uh crime
which is exactly what it is and make an
example out of the person who leaked
this information because our supreme
court justices cannot operate under the
fear that they will have partisan
political activists in their house
intimidating and threatening their
ability to do their job per the
constitution okay
so tulsi uses the word thief and that
sounds criminal i don't know theft is
illegal right
but it wasn't that we know of a crime so
that's one thing i'm going to talk about
the second piece of this is she insists
that this was
uh someone who didn't like
the forthcoming decision to overturn roe
v wade
meaning it's presumably someone on the
left who leaked this in order to try to
pressure the justices to change their
minds and sometime between now and
whenever the decision comes out
decide to preserve roe v wade i'll get
to that part in a second so let's start
with the crime piece this is not about
your opinion of whether it was good or
bad that this leaked three weeks early i
just want to talk about whether it's a
crime if to get to this document
someone at the supreme court
hacked a computer they weren't supposed
to have access to
physically trespassed somewhere that
could be a crime we have no evidence
of any hacking or trespassing right now
secondly supreme court draft decisions
are not classified that's another angle
where this is sort this must be like a
classified document it's not so there's
no crime there either
if i want to be as charitable as
possible and say where could there be a
crime here
under the loosest interpretation
possible
you could maybe be charged with stealing
federal government property for your own
use it's extraordinarily unlikely that
you would see that it's not even clear
that it would necessarily fit now if an
investigation starts
and
authorities interview anyone the leaker
or whoever and you lie to them okay
that's a crime that would be making a
federal false uh statement charge
but that's an if okay so
there's no crime that we're aware of
here so why would anybody be prosecuted
and locked up because that's what people
like tulsi and other reactionaries are
calling for now one other thing if the
leaker is a lawyer
they could be subject to an ethics probe
they could be subject to being disbarred
it's these aren't crimes but they could
lose their law license bottom line
firing sure disbarment if a lawyer sure
crime almost certainly not no evidence
of that at this point in time second
part
they continue to assume these
right-wingers
that the leaker
is a pro-choice
left-winger
angry with the forthcoming decision to
overturn roe v wade
releasing this draft in order to try to
put public pressure on the justices
planning to vote in favor of overturning
roe v wade so they will be scared and
they'll change their mind and they will
vote to keep roe v wade first of all
lifetime appointments
extremely good security i don't even
think it passes the sniff test that it
would work if that's what the plan was
to intimidate the justices planning to
vote to overturn but i actually have
another perspective here which is
we're we're only speculating we don't
know who the leaker is
the leaker could just as likely be a
right winger
who leaked this
in order to try to lock in the justices
in sticking with their decision to
overturn roe v wade in other words a
right winger might say
there might be justices who in this
february draft
wanted to vote to overturn roe v wade
but now maybe because it's may now
remember this person might know what
happened since the draft was written
maybe the leaker is a right winger
doesn't like abortion and says wow i
found out that i don't know gorsuch is
thinking about actually voting to keep
roe v wade
i am going to leak this to make their
names public
so that they are less likely to change
their vote because that would
potentially cause some kind of uproar or
whatever the point is we don't know
either way right now at some point we
might right now we don't know and all of
this is completely irresponsible
particularly saying that people who have
not committed any crime that we're aware
of or that can be articulated should be
prosecuted and put in prison as so many
like ted cruz have been demanding
one other clip i want to look at related
to
the supreme court leaker so we had a
more serious discussion a few minutes
ago in the context of what tulsi gabbard
said about the kind of equal likelihood
based on what we know right now that the
leaker might have been someone on the
left who supports abortion rights or
someone on the right who's against
abortion rights we just don't know one
way or the other
but now i want to play for you a clip
from newsmax
where uh the host grant stinkfield with
absolutely no evidence whatsoever
speculates that it might be
the not yet on the court but confirmed
justice katanji brown jackson who leaked
the draft now there's no evidence of
that she's also not on the court and how
she would have access to the draft i
don't know but here's grant stinkfield's
perspective
we're not telling them what they can do
to their bodies though we're telling
them what they can't do to a baby a
precious life and speaking of catanje
brown jackson you just saw there
i find it suspect that the first leak
coming out of the supreme court in
history
comes shortly after judge jackson is
confirmed i want to know if her law
clerks who i am sure have already been
hired possibly even working at the high
court already before her swearing-in
have access to these draft decisions
she would be my first suspect when it
comes to the leak because catanje brown
by the way katanje they just can't get
it right jackson is a radical left-wing
activist more radical than any other
justice in the history of the supreme
court i think what he means is as
qualified as any other justice on the
supreme court so we don't know who it
was this is total speculation it might
have been someone on the left it might
have been someone on the right we know
why each side might have motivations to
leak this
but
katanji brown jackson is not on the
court
there is no evidence that i was able to
find
that her forthcoming clerks are already
at the supreme court with access to
documents there's just no evidence of
this whatsoever and understand i don't
know if this the hypothesis is going to
pick up steam
but the way that it'll work is newsmax
will float it without evidence
and then people on twitter will talk
about it
and then tucker will say there are many
people saying
it might have been katanji brown jackson
it's what he did with the vaccines
remember oh um it might uh there are
people saying tens of thousands of
people died from the covet vaccines i'm
not saying that but there are people
saying that and then all of a sudden
it's on fox news at night and then the
next day fox news the hard news program
say
uh tucker carlson last night said that
and that's how it gets into the news
cycle so we'll see what kind of life
this hypothesis about katanji brown
jackson being the leaker um
gets i hope that it's not much but there
is absolutely no evidence and it
violates a a absolute and complete um uh
instinct
where she's not even working there
there's no reason to think her clerks
are there there's no reason to think
katanji brown jackson has anything to do
with this
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's an interesting voicemail about
hipaa vaccines and the roe v wade
decision take a listen to this
hey david i was just thinking this
morning
why is it that when it comes to
vaccinations
the republicans are all worried about
their hipaa yes
but when it comes to abortions that's
everybody's business
okay so i like the call i
in in truth none of this really is about
hipaa remember that hipaa is about
privacy regulations that govern
medical providers medical providers it
doesn't apply
to
legislators or journalists or whatever
anyway
but the point here is a good one which
is with something that relates to
communicable and contagious disease
which you could argue
i am affected by the person next to me
they say oh you can't even ask about
vaccine status never mind require a
vaccine and yet here when it comes to
something that's non-communicable and is
a personal decision
they seem to not care whatsoever about
the ability of an individual to make the
medical decision that's best for them
with their doctors and the council of
medical professionals that is absolutely
a double standard and i'm glad that it
is being pointed out but good luck
convincing these people of anything they
are they're gone to quote alex jones we
have a bonus show we do it every day the
bonus show is an additional show that we
do for our members you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access to
the bonus show you can also use the uh
coupon code obama to get a discount
today's bonus show we will talk about
remember all those issues with the
unruly
airline passengers in the immediate
aftermath i guess we would say of the
pandemic those unruly passenger problems
have plummeted to a multi-year low we'll
talk about why and what's going on
secondly
intuit which is the company that makes
turbo tax is going to have to pay
a 140 plus million dollar settlement
over their supposedly free turbo tax
which isn't really free i have a lot to
say about that and we're going to talk
about it and thirdly a judge has ruled
that an arizona prisoner is
psychologically fit
to be executed how backwards is this
death penalty my friends how backwards
is this death penalty all of those
stories and more we will discuss on
today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com get access otherwise
i'll see you back tomorrow on the friday